cool hello everyone first I'd like to
say that it's really cool to be here
because two more
we're moving into this office into TQ so
from tomorrow we'll be here and this is
my second week that I now live in
Amsterdam I moved here first of August
so I'm still looking for friends so if
anyone wants to become my friend touch
me after well poke me after this talk
and I'll consider you a friend
okay so my name is eva spell hora which
is a very hard name to pronounce even in
the netherlands so you can call me Eve's
you can call me Ives and my friends have
more trouble with my name than anyone
else
they call me flip if you want to call me
flip that's fine as well I respond to it
I am co-founder of something called code
sandbox who if you have heard of code
samples before really cool nice even
though it's quite known I'm gonna show
the homepage because that's what I'm
most proud of I've worked for three days
on this animation so promised myself to
ever show it every time so I was
thinking for April 1st I should make a
sound board or something in code sandbox
that you can actually well have sounds
when you click myself but this is code
sandbox it's kind of like your local
editor oh no one ever gone it's kind of
like your local editor but there's a
preview here so you can do typing and it
will update and you can add NPM
dependencies and you'll have multiple
files and the idea is that we want to
kind of have the exact same feeling as
your local code editor so that you can
so that you don't have to learn two
environments so that's in a nutshell
what code sandbox is this talk I want to
talk about the story of code sandbox how
it came to be how it started how it came
here and in between I will give some
small demos and some technical
explanations I'd say and whenever I'm on
minutes when evils can someone like put
up their hands so I know when I'm on
minute 20
we'll see okay so let's start the story
three years back I went to my first
conference ever it was called react
Europe and at the conference I was new
to everything there was there were many
talks and the talks were mostly about
what people built in the open-source
space and I was super inspired by this
whole ambience like how people were
building and showing everything and I
thought oh I want to contribute to the
open-source space as well so three years
back I decided to well get my hands
dirty and I started writing notes every
time I had a problem I would think of a
solution and I would write it down on
this list and that was mostly it I of
course didn't do anything with the ideas
I first started going on vacation I went
on vacation to village called st. Ives
and you can guess why we went there and
while I was on vacation we were I worked
at a company we were converting Ruby on
Rails pages to react and when I was
there I got a lot of questions from my
co-workers about react in combination
with Redux so they sent me coach
snippets on slack we didn't even have
codes syntax highlighting it was very
bad and I had to parse their code
through my own head because I didn't
have my laptop with me and think what
the problem might be so that was one of
the problems that i den had and I wrote
down that it would be super cool if
people could put their these code
snippets from their local editor in the
browser where they have a URL that they
can share with others and then others
can view it as well so the question was
what if I put my local editor on the web
and of course I put it right here there
and again I didn't do much with the was
the idea I started studying and I
started drinking a lot of beer going to
a lot of parties the co-founder of code
sandbox is also here and this is me
but after a while when I was doing more
partying than really learning I started
to feel a bit unproductive if you look
at my contribution graph this is when I
started studying and this part is just
empty and I felt unproductive and it
didn't feel very nice so I've decided
that during specifically my Java
lectures I started working on one of the
ideas which was the first one a browser
react editor that allows you to create
components instantly it was a very vague
description so I started with a very
fake design it's in sketch it's called
free exam books it's one of the best
designs I've ever made and it was very
simple you had CSS here JavaScript here
and then you have these buttons on the
Left which were supposed to be
components and this would have been the
preview I didn't do long with the design
I just started trying to implement it
and I remember being super happy with
this already it was a code a preview and
when you changed the code it would
actually update the preview instantly I
was so happy with this that I started to
add more and more to it so the next
version you have already multiple tabs
and the interesting behavior here is
that if you import from the tab then it
would take that code and use that code
instead and that was it was a very
simple implementation I'd say there were
two applications you have the code
editor and you have to preview the
preview is a separate application that's
rendered in an iframe then whenever you
change something in the code editor it
would use post message to send all the
files to the preview and it will
transpile which is making the code
readable by the browser and then
evaluate the code and the implementation
I rebuilt the implementation in codes
and works to keep the inception levels
high so this is it it's a bit different
design
I didn't you sketch this time to map it
all out but how it works is this is the
source code the top one this is the
transpiled code and this is a file and
this is the other file it's a react
application and what I want to mostly
come
on how it works is it's also using hooks
I am very modern and what I want to
cover is run code so run code this is
everything that was done to make the
code evaluate what happens is we take we
have an object which is called files and
it has keys for the filenames and then
code as a string it takes the code it
transforms this code so it trans pass
the code using Babel transform and then
it starts evaluating the code with the
evil eval so everyone's telling me don't
use eval well code sandbox is built upon
eval that's next level hacker man I'm
very proud of this so it will run the
code and the interesting thing area are
these variables you have require exports
and module these variables since disco
dizzy felt in this context are available
in the code itself so if you look at
this transport code this is what it
evaluates it doesn't require which will
mean that it will call this function and
this function recursively calls for
encode again and then does the same flow
again so the cool thing is that this
will already work when you call run it
says hello well this is not applicable
and it will do this and the reason that
it works is because it does this require
here and that require runs the code
again and it returns the module of
exports and if you look at this
transpose code it does exports to agreed
is this function and that's what's
returned so that wasn't a nutshell how
code Sam was worth I started to do more
UI work after this so the next thing
that I had as the idea was that you
could build projects on code sandbox and
then import those projects and other
projects on code sandbox it was very
cool because you would make these like
mini npm libraries that you can then
reuse so everyone could build their own
library on code samox and then you could
see them in your actual project but it
turns out that's that this looks
very much like your file explorer so I
decided to just make it a file explorer
instead the funny thing is that you can
see that I didn't start with the idea of
an online code editor I started with the
idea of some crazy stuff and this is
starting to look a bit like code sandbox
already it even had now has the name
code sandbox instead of react sandbox
then twelve days later and some duchies
will no diskette normally says Anna and
this is already looking a lot like code
sandbox we got support for NPM
dependencies here which is dynamically
downloaded from unpackage at the time
and you can kind of see that it didn't
start with the react editor s idea it
started with the component editor that
was the initial idea then a component
library build a way you can we implement
libraries in your own library and then I
wanted to make it online so you can
publish your library and then other
people can input it and then it started
to become very complicated so I just
said okay well let's make it an online
react editor around this time bus joint
as well buses somewhere here as well
he's co-founder Darius we do every
project together we know we've known
each other since we were 12 so the idea
is that I learned is that I should let
the idea evolve the final version of
code semak's was not thought of in the
first version so even if you have an
idea I would just start working on it
then you will figure out the details
over time maybe you'll do an extremely
big pivot of going to from a component
edit sort of component library builder
to to an online code editor so 26 of
January it started to shape up it was
looking like a real editor but then I
lost motivation very very useful I I saw
code symbols every day and every day I
started to get less impressed by it
because I saw it every day so it started
to get a lot very normal to me
so one of the things that I did then was
I went back to the lectures because I
stopped working on it and my friends
there
they asked me hey where have you been
these past couple months and that's when
I showed them code sandbox and
they got much more enthusiastic about
coats and less than L was expecting so
that gave me a bit more motivation again
and you can see that I stopped working
on here and I said to myself at that
point okay I'm going to work on coats
and books we're going to try to finish
every feature before the 1st of April
every feature that's not finished by the
1st of April will be dropped so
naturally you can see this huge spike of
development and a lot of Fiji's were
actually dropped because on the 1st of
april not everything was finished but we
decided to release anyway so there's
there's the thing that I learned that I
should always seek for external feedback
in my case I like seeing people use the
products I like people being
enthusiastic so that gave me gives me
motivation I should also have tried to
release faster I was doing a lot of work
on top which in the end some things were
actually dropped from coats AMEX and it
turns out that no one needed them so I
didn't reinvent them ever after and
follow kiss keep keep a simple approach
you can say keep it simple stupid or you
can say keep it simple stupid and I like
the latter version for example for the
file system I was thinking of like five
different systems for the file system
then I thought oh this is all over
engineering I should just put everything
in Postgres database now three years
later we have more than 15 million files
and they are still all stored in a
Postgres database
it sounds very scary that works very
well so don't over engineer keep it keep
a simple implementation over time you
can see based on the requirements what
the actual implementation should be then
I released it - well I had 60 followers
at the time so I created this tweet and
I got a whopping six likes all from my
high school friends
and I didn't they didn't even know what
they weren't even in coding so it was
very yeah that was that was a bummer so
I decided to post on Reddit and it got a
lot more response there and this is kind
of when it kicked off I started a lot to
do a lot of talking with people who were
using it and started writing medium post
and slowly over time you could see
people picking it up that was super cool
for this is one of my favorite things
then ever move tweeted when he still had
this orange pink thing he treated about
how cool code samox was I was so
enthusiastic that I made a snap of it
like a snapchat snap you can see that
because of this this means this is so
cool
for the translation and you can see that
ice and this is I send this to all my
high school friends again and they
didn't understand it then I also got
feedback saying marry me I'm in love
with you this is delicious thank you
I've included you in my will I still
need to find this person and even at
some point we were on hacker noon and
that well that made me super
enthusiastic as well so as you can
imagine I made this very scientific
graph of how s code someone's got more
popular you could see that my vast
accident went down I did pretty bad at
my university which others really didn't
understand it I found it pretty hard to
concentrate on learning math when I got
like messages and people using codes and
books so at some point I decided what AM
what am I actually doing and I decided
to pause my studies at that time my
excuse was to pause it I'm still in a
past state of my studies even though we
have a company of ten people but I
decided to pause it and we started to
write now some values because we're an
open-source project we got a lot of
feature requests so we had to kind of
categorize which feature requests which
features we wanted to implement as first
thing the first one is lowered learning
curve
second one is encourage sharing and
discovery and the third one is give a
local editor experience trademark and I
want to explain the values and then give
an explanation on how it kind of
resolves in what's implemented in code
sandbox the first one is lower the
learning curve one of the things that I
didn't really think of when releasing
code sandbox is that people use it to
learn web development on code sandbox
and that is super interesting and it
makes a lot of sense because people
don't have to set up an environment
before they can get started they have to
go to they just have to go to a web site
start editing the white text and they've
changed the web and web application they
can call themselves a developer which is
also my preferred way of learning in the
end you don't hopefully you don't spend
most of your time in the built on build
tools environment setting that up and I
think it makes sense to first actually
taste how it is to build an application
before you start learn
how to well do the build tools so that
was really cool one of the things that
we do here that I find very nice is for
some errors because we have full control
over the whole environment we can detect
everything so for some of the things
that we do we change the errors to make
them a bit more friendly for example if
I would want to change this hello
components to well I'll just change the
import to hallo normally you get this
error 'invalid character an error filled
to execute create elements on document
the tag name provider blah blah blah
blah blah we have seen already that this
file doesn't have an extension so it's
imported as a raw module so we change
the error a bit saying it seems like
English that yes is importing a raw
module hello hallo very Dutch and we
give suggestion rename hello - hello
Dutch is and if you click it is renamed
and it works so that is one of the
things that we do we have this thing
called error transformers where we use
the environment we catch an error and
things say like oh maybe we can actually
provide something useful here
the second thing second value is
occurred sharing and discovery so
Cosimo's was built for sharing but it
turns out that there is a goldmine of
information on code sandbox one of the
things that we do is we have an embed
which allows customs to be shared in
articles for example on documentation
people can play with it and have some
real feedback but the thing that I find
most interesting is our search page so
we have a search page which which was
broken at 5 p.m. today and that's why I
was very stressed but we have a search
page where you can see everything
created on code sandbox there are now
two point five million sandbox is here
the cool thing is if you want to learn
like a library you can get all the sand
boxes of this library for example if you
want under how Redux thunk is
implemented you can filter on all the
sandbox that have been created with this
readers phone library so you can use
that as kind of like a reference point
and that's very interesting there's a
lot more that we want to do one of the
things is that we have an explorer page
where you can see cool creations like I
love
this and well this one is also cool okay
next the last one is local editor
experience there are two reasons that we
want to know have local editor
experience for the experienced developer
we don't want them to learn a new
environment one day prototype something
or want to share something on code
sandbox the second reason is that if a
beginner starts to learn web development
in code sandbox if they at some point go
local we prefer that they also won't
have to learn a new environment so that
it all works the same one of the things
that we do is that this part is all free
s code it's the literal implementation
of it's it's a little port of es code so
what I want to do here I want to quickly
explain at the story of how vs code got
implemented it started with this
announcement themes Sara and I were
attending a workshop of Sara Dresner she
was using niteowl as their as her editor
theme and we were thinking wow it would
be super cool to also have Fiasco themes
in code sandbox so we started to look at
Fiasco themes and it turns out that the
implementation of a fiasco theme is a
JSON file which makes everything a bit
easier because the thing that we were
able to do here we use style components
we just put the whole theme file on as a
context prop for the style components
implementation and we were able to refer
to the theme and then with a small
fallback
but this allowed us to put the JSON file
on the context and then you have
multiple themes wait maybe I can well I
need to has to do this how do you mmm
yeah color theme and you can use
different themes you can you have many
Wow
I see everyone light up suddenly but
there was one problem and one challenge
in this implementation who knows who
knows this I can you do
Wow that's that's very impressive okay
so this this is a text mate I can text
mate was an incredibly popular editor
for a very long time especially in web
development and they introduced
something called TM language TM language
is a specification of how code should be
colored so how coach should be tokenized
so when you have a part of code saying
it's like let's a is five it would say
let's is a keyword a variable name five
numeric the challenge of this is well
the cool thing here is that lots of
editors after this also implemented this
specification so Adam uses this Fiasco
uses this but there is a challenge here
because TM language is where users back
expressions which can only be parsed by
a library called only guru ma
only guru my as a seed library and we've
been trying to first port it to the
browser a year ago by converting the C
code to JavaScript it turns out to be 30
times slower so you're parsing well your
syntax highlighting would be super slow
but when we now live in modern times and
we have what web assembly and it was
super cool because nice and oh he made
something called Oni gasm yeah it's a
web assembly implementation of the c
library and it's actually very fast it's
almost as close as 2 C implementation
and I think at some point we'll get to
the same performance this is by the way
small off-road thing webassembly is
super cool I recommend anyone to learn
for us it's also very cool so yeah it's
a weapon sembly is a small future it
will help with web application
development a lot then when we released
it everyone was an enthusiastic but
there was one person who said would
about extensions I mean it makes sense
right it's you have Fiasco theme support
so extensions must be only one small
step forward no that's not true with
context it's yeah that's it would be
created to support extensions especially
since we support
especially since we have I was doing a
Facebook internship at the time as well
so I was full-time doing an internship
and then also this but of course must be
fun to try so challenge accepted
let's give me I'll give you a very small
crash course of how V s code extensions
work so you have V s code itself with
its UI and extensions are executed in a
separate node process the extension host
this has a lot of advantages and makes
PS code very fast because the vs code
people they don't control what
extensions do so making them run in a
separate hose allows them to still keep
like snappy snappy behavior in PS code
itself while while still allowing
extensions the other thing that really
cool is that they can just restart the
extension host at any time without
restarting free s code and the only
thing that you'll notice is that for
some moments you won't have auto
completions or or you won't have to go
to definitions and the extension host
can also spawn processes like TS server
so this is how the s code extensions
work now making it work with code
sandbox was a bit more challenging
because code sandwich was not running
for yes code so the idea that I
initially had was to create a bridge
between the code sandbox and the
extension hose so we would run the
extension host in the browser in a web
worker and then we would convert all the
calls all the messages from the
extension host in code sandbox to
something that would work in code
sandbox it turns out that there was so
much work especially if you are like if
you have four hours a day converting
every API call to a compatible version
in code sandbox was too much work so the
next crazy thing was to actually run PS
code in code sandbox so that we wouldn't
have to convert all the API calls and
make it work so that was the first that
was the first crazy idea to try and the
first implementation went horribly wrong
the idea was so this is how es code as
the application works it's an electron
process so you have the main process and
the main process can spawn render
processes and this is actually what
draws the UI and all of these processes
the main and the renderer processes have
to the native modules which talked to
the operating system like a fast
Nats TTY modulized vos my initial
implementation was let's stop all the
modules so try to make all the native
modules work directly in the browser in
code sandbox again like the last
implementation this turned out to be too
much work implementing file system in
the browser that's that's okay but
suddenly you talked with you talk about
implementing nets and implementing t2i
and that was a lot of extra work so the
second implementation I started to look
into the code base of es code itself and
it's architected very C sharp like it's
very interesting you have a lot of
different services in vs code and all of
these services are responsible for their
own part of the system so you have the
editor service which is responsible for
rendering the editor you have to file
service for talking to FS you have
request service for doing requests and
these services they can require each
other in their construct so these are
all classes and they can be dynamically
injected so the editor service might
need to file service to get the file
file service might need the notification
service to say that the file was not
saved correctly and so on so my next
implementation was the idea of creating
a cosign book service which we talked to
code sandbox and then re implementing
these services and overriding them with
our own version and these services they
would use code sandbox so let's say we
have the file service it talks to code
symbols to get the files instead of FS
the requirements of this implementation
were that we shouldn't change any
existing code because we wanted to stay
up-to-date with the vs code code base so
we wanted to keep the merge conflicts
down so the goal was to not change any
code of PS code that was pretty hard so
we do have a few minimal changes but the
advantage is now that when we merge with
the fierce code code base it takes like
well I think two days or something to
catch up to two months of development on
vs code and free s code has a lot of
developments the amount of commits every
time you go to the repository s code
someone at least made one commit in the
last half hour it's crazy the second
requirement was to expose PS code as an
API so that when you have outside
contributors looking at the code sandbox
codebase they wouldn't have to learn
Fiasco to add like a menu item to vs
code so we exposed for example the
ability to add menu items to vs code by
just calling some coding codes and books
itself and it should be fast and small
electronic legations they don't need to
do a lot of tree shaking or code
splitting code splitting in our case it
was needed so we had we wrote a tree
shaking implemented well I wrote a -
tree shaking implementation of vs code
to look at which modules were used and
which modules were not using there are a
lot of tricky things here for example
reactors declarative vs code is
incredibly imperative we use webpack vs
code uses AMD loader for some people who
still remember AMD but the advantages
are also big is updatable so every time
the PS code has an update we can merge
it we can take a day and we'll have the
new vs code in code sandbox we're not
reinventing the wheel I even found some
new features in PS code while
implementing it in code sandbox which is
really cool and you can stay familiar
with the existing editor we do now also
have extension support so it's still you
can still you cannot install your custom
extensions yet but that's one of the
plans in the future but it works very
much like your own editor and this is
the final implementation and one of the
cool things I always like to show is
that it's so real that mmm I can even so
you have to configure this can close and
you can move so I can even take my
existing configuration from my code
editor and I can face it here and save
and it will change my editor to be like
well and it will fork assembles of
course and it will change my editor to
be like my implementation of the base
editor and works with key bindings it
works with your settings it works with a
lot of we can even reuse the same
extension from fiasco to have film
support so you can do a lot of things
that are implemented here
you want to talk more about how V s code
extensions are implemented in code sign
books that's a whole other story where
we re implemented runtime in a web
worker that's for at drinks that I need
a couple beers yeah that's a lot of work
and in the meantime on the business side
we decided to grow the team so we've
raised an investment of 2.4 million
dollars from kleiner perkins and some
really cool founders for example Kuhn
from framer Dylan from figma the
founders of net loaf I founder of side
source Graff founder so it's we've we
have a lot of advisers and we're now
growing the team so right now we're nine
people the last two weeks we had a
get-together of code somewhere remote
first and two from next month so first
of September will be ten people and
another thing that can be done in this
scientific graph that as more people
start working on code sandbox I start to
work on code less and I think this can
be like a part two of this talk about
how suddenly your shift you're shifting
from doing a lot of coding to doing more
writing documents instead in notion as
the boss buses like the notion master so
that's I'm still safe from that but
that's I still need to learn how to how
to handle this and that will be like for
the next time I think so thanks a lot
for listening this is our get ours
student house cat sitting on my keyboard
and now my keys are sticky so it's a bad
story but it's a nice guy thanks a lot
[Applause]